swe God Different Strokes for
different it should be personal
reference yeah it's all
good what do we got users twitch emotes
in
conversation uh
okay uh oh god well technically copium
is a twitch emote yeah I know yeah yeah
there's a lot of twitch em all right
ready 3 two one red red okay if it's a
friend no problems with it it's whatever
I'm first with someone they say pogies
to me I'm or ooo anything like that I'm
like all right I'm out yeah yeah this
restaurant I'm it's Ki W right now yeah
yeah you know if if I'm if I'm in sleep
I guess if I'm in any kind of situation
other than a [__] like twitch con or
like an anime convention if I'm talking
to streamers or something yeah if I go
on Tinder and we get in the conversation
and they unironically use a twitch emote
I'm like no I didn't think I didn't
think I would get a reply back mon ass
then I'm like all right it's Swip like
what that shows me is this person is
terminally online which of course they
are like us uh one I kind of want to get
away from that and two uh I don't even I
I rarely even use twitch emotes even
though it's like our job in like our
conversation it's pogers yeah pogers is
just every time every time Connor says
like a Twitchy Mo most of the time I
tell them to shut the [__] up I value
being able to be a social chameleon
right I like being able to if you throw
me in a in a dinner with a bunch of
Stuffy Bankers I could probably I could
probably have some conversations there
and I would love to see that they
wouldn't they wouldn't know you know
that I'm a twitch streamer I think I I'd
be completely fine the purple shirt obv
I'd be wearing something different i'
wear something different if I wanted to
fit in I could and and I value being
able to be able to fit in whichever
scenario cuz if you come in right first
dat you're going pogies oh this food is
uh is pogers and then I'm thinking like
man when I introdu to my parents this is
going to be tough you know what I mean
like I have I'm thinking about
that it's I'm thinking long games come
on like I I you know I can't be like
don't [__] say Kappa once during this
dinner okay I don't want to have to have
that conversation it's like so so how
just imagine like the boyfriend's
parents talking to the girlfriend saying
like so how is he treating you it's like
here to go no cap yeah it's pretty it's
pretty it's pretty Pepe hands right now
it's it's just like if if they think Big
W not like this no way if they if they
think yeah if if they think that you
know it's socially acceptable on like a
first date to just start spamming the
twitch emotes IRL um like to I'm imag to
the streets I'm imagining to the chat
with you I'm imagining what kind of like
situations would they also be
comfortable spamming twitch emotes like
whatever belongs in the chat what if
what if we're not and she goes pogies
yeah yeah yeah what if we're in
bed yo that was a gold split right there
ain't no way Ain't No Way ain't no way a
no
way that sounds [__] horrible yeah
thank God when they see my three- in
amkus ain't no way no in general though
I have um it doesn't just like I guess
stop at twitch emotes if they start like
pumping out the Discord memes in like
everyday conversation you know we we we
we got to have a chat we got to have a
chat as well did you C suck
I feel like get off of me the word come
has been ruined for me I always get like
in my head there's that Split Second
someone says
come I'm like so my brain is broken yeah
all right bring on the next
flag a [__] long one oh I got two
that's why what do we got she talks
about marriage on a first
date
ooh okay ooh
okay so this is assuming you're not in
the committed relationship yet you're
just on date first dat it says she talks
about marriage on the first
dat uh okay all right I'm ready
gentlemen all right I think I'm ready as
well all right ready 3 2 1 red none
green really yeah oh okay this is I was
almost I was almost going to put green
uh because
uh yeah like I think that I've seen too
many people where they hit these
relationship crossroads right A lot of
them come like a lot of them start
dating get along really well date for
years and then everyone hits this
relationship Crossroads do we want to
get married do you ever want to get
married or and do you ever want to have
kids and I've seen so many couples that
have like had just their world destroyed
destroy because they don't want to break
up with this person but they also don't
want to compromise on this very very
important thing which you're allowed to
make a live decision on which is some
people just don't want to get married
and that's respectable I I think you can
be very happy together as a couple and
have it all be perfect and then it'd be
a valid reason to not want to be with
someone any longer because they don't
want to marry like I think to some
people okay I didn't think of it like
that is such a that is like you know I
think it's personal preference like
maybe like I just thought way too far
right right right I think
that's that's fair as well I don't even
know you you know for me it's like I'd
rather you tell me right now what you
what you're hoping to get eventually cuz
that's not that's not you saying to me
hey we have to get married it kind of is
but it's also like hey that's how I see
this is my intention is to look someone
to marry which is what you know I most
people are looking for sure in a
roundabout way and I think expressing
that that is something that you are
interested in or not interested in
initially is a considerate thing to do
and I think making sure that your
intentions are out right at the
beginning of the relationship I think is
respectable you know because if You'
asked me 5 years ago it would have been
a red flag cuz I was young and I was
like what the [__] but I think the older
I get the more I'm like yeah I think
it's something that especially as you
get older it's something that has to be
discussed and why not get it out of the
way and too many people like too many
people like kind of like sweep this
under the rug to be like we'll figure it
out eventually and they put it off and
then obviously you reach with kids right
kids I think more so with kids I think
getting married is kind of like we get
married but kids is always the normally
a pretty can can be a decisive thing and
the thing is I've seen people of that
have compromised on this like big life
decision to be like well I don't want to
break up so I'm going to want I'm going
to get married and then it always sounds
like you're in green g I don't know I
don't know if it know sounds like you're
in green yeah that sounds very green
what you're saying you want you don't
want to commit to the green squad here
like what's wrong commit he said green
way too many times in the first half of
this episode so he's got to make a
compromise
so when what's the downside then cuz you
put on what's the downside uh like to me
like it's neither a red flag or a green
flag it's just like okay I understand
your intentions uh we can decide later
like I can have this in mind so I can
decide it later on but as long as the
intentions are out that doesn't mean
that doesn't mean [__] to me you know it
means I know that if I like if I want to
commit to this relationship I know that
that is the end goal
cuz I said red because it's just a bit
too much pressure on a
first get zomi on a first date bro like
you know I I get it you know like cuz I
totally get what you mean with like you
know just get all of like that kind of
out of the way in the beginning but a
ton of context that could be missing
here like is this a first blind date is
this a date where you've but you've
already spoken for months and I was
thinking of like a blind day that's fair
yeah if it's a blind day I still think
it's valid
yeah but like for me it's like okay you
know what I I just want to get to like
you as a person before I even want to
know about what you want for me I
something like that just puts pressure
on me I like well I guess if if it puts
pressure on you why would you be feeling
pressure about it cuz you feel like
they're trying to marry you or like well
yeah because the way that they say it
could be putting it in that way of being
like I'm so desperate and like you know
I need someone to you know do XYZ and
all that kind of stuff and I am afraid
that I won't be able to commit that you
know and like for me on a first date I
want to just get to know you as a person
that's fair I don't care about like you
know where you want to be in 10 years or
anything like that I just want to know
you right now like what your present
state is maybe third or fourth date sure
then we can start out then more cuz
you're now you're like it's kind of
working and now you feel like you got to
say yes to the marriage cuz she wants to
get married I don't know but for me it's
just like a bit icky when it happens on
the first but that's just me okay that's
just me jaie didn't say it on the first
day thankfully she didn't say it on the
first day all right let's see and oh
Jesus okay all right uh okay takes more
than 30 minutes to get
dressed 30 minutes is such an arbitrary
number you know that's uh can I can can
I say that's quick no that's takes
longer than 30 minutes that's so long
bro 30 minutes is quick are we including
Shower time does shower time count no
just getting ready okay okay good good I
was going to take a shower time like
yeah like they're sitting on the couch
and you go honey we're going to go I'm
I'm not crazy 30 minutes is quick right
I think if you're depends wait wait wait
wait okay wait okay hold up hold up
what's the okay we need way more context
situation okay when when are we waking
up or are we are we going out for dinner
like I thought you meant going out for
dinner you know okay so presumably
you're already like show hood and
everything you're just putting on make
and dress I guess makeup dress Jewelry
accessories all that kind of stuff shoes
I don't know I I'll be real with you I
I'm playing video games so
I I just say when we like I'll just tell
you say whenever you're ready I'm like
this is when we're going to leave just
get ready for that I don't care if it
takes you 15 hours just be ready to go
at this time how early are you letting
them know and well you mean I just I
just trying to be punctual what what if
it's like what if it's just like a super
like last minute decision you know
you're both just like hanging out at
home you want to do something and you
just happen to have the idea of hey you
know what so it's nothing crazy right
it's not like no just like being like
hey hey honey let's go out for dinner
get ready and they take more than 30
minutes is that a red flag or a green
flag if it was longer than an hour it'd
be red because it's 30 I'll say non I'm
going to say non
like I said 30 30 is very quick how long
does C on average take
huh um so like very much depends if it's
like a fancy night then she needs she
needs an hour like just like yeah I
think anything over an hour that's still
that's still quick for a fancy night
that's quick my Lord that's that's what
I'm saying that's what I'm saying ref if
this is like a good
number we've been in long enough
relationships enough to know a fancy
night hour it's like wa are you
compromising something like what you not
putting in the effort any of your
previous relationships they like ever
reach this point yeah cuz this like
obviously like you know I've been in
multiple relationships and in my in my
frame of reference 30 minutes has been a
very very quick turnaround I'll be real
I I will if I leave with the person I
would be like hey I'm leav we're leaving
at this time be ready and I don't really
keep track of how long it takes I just
know if it runs over I'm like oh I guess
like come on I see like 40 minutes late
to a thing I'm like come on yeah oh yeah
that's that be it's not like it's your
first time doing this it's it's it's
it's okay if they're late is something
different but like I know I know the
lead time my partner needs in order to
like do like yeah do something n knows
exactly when to start the
split I value being punctual a lot so
I'm like let's be punctual yeah it's
it's it's like if they're late okay
that's something that is a red flag you
know but
uh like in terms of how I don't really
care how how long it takes you to get
ready as long as you know how long it
takes you to get ready you yeah and some
people they take over an hour and uh
that's just how long they take you know
I don't really care that much I'll be
real I'm going to be real I'm like honey
I'mma watch some anime while you spend
like I'll do something I'm not there
with as long as we're there on time and
you look amazing that's all I care about
one